[Music]
there's a weapon that powerful countries
use to get rid of leaders they don't
like leaders from other countries it's
called a coup it's a French word that
means a punch or a blow because it kind
of means coming in and forcibly punching
out a government from Power no elections
no process just power being seized
someone being pushed out and someone
being put in coups happen in so many
different ways but I want to show you
how the coup has been used by the United
States of America as a tool to get what
they want on the world stage so let me
walk you through some of the major U.S
led coups over the years to show you
that while it sometimes seems like we
live in a world full of order and rules
the reality is that the most powerful
countries will often get their way by
whatever means necessary
okay so here's how I'm defining the
us-led coups that I'm going to put on
our list here number one they were
successful there's a lot of failed coup
attempts we're leaving those out number
two there must be at least one U.S
government official involved in the coup
and number three we need concrete
evidence that the US was actually
involved not just speculation while the
U.S has been involved in tons of regime
change efforts around the world we
landed on a much shorter list these are
the coups that I think best exemplify
how this tool has been used for
international power over the years
[Music]
foreign
let's start here
in the independent country of Hawaii
it's 1893 and the US is feeling like the
Hawaiian Queen is a threat to American
control over sugar it's sugar that's
being grown by the descendants of white
American missionaries who had settled in
Hawaii over the years so the U.S sends a
military ship with hundreds of troops to
show up to Honolulu and they overthrow
the queen installing one of those
descendants of the Christian
missionaries Sanford B Dole as the new
president notice his last name yeah this
coup was one of the US's first and it
set the stage not only for the new
Hawaiian president's family to grow
their powerful international corporation
which was based in Hawaii but also for
Hawaii to be annexed to become a part of
the United States I made a whole video
on this coup because it's pretty wild
and there's so much going on here and it
was really a turning point in showing
how the U.S could remove leaders from
power in Faraway places something that
they start to do a lot more of
we're going to move on to the next coup
but I need to thank today's sponsor who
makes these videos possible thank you
nordvpn for sponsoring today's video
I've started using nordvpn for a lot of
different things when I'm traveling I
connect to the internet via the United
States so that all of my accounts don't
freak out thinking that like I'm someone
from another country logging into my
accounts oh and by the way that allows
me to like watch Netflix from different
countries as well which is kind of cool
but it's more than that it is a password
manager it is a malware blocker it
blocks annoying ads it helps you encrypt
files it provides all these layers of
extra security which more and more is
something that we all need and the best
part is you don't have to be like a
technical person to do this like it's
one click away and you have all this
protection or you can have it just
connect automatically and you just have
it running in the background and not
just for one computer when you sign up
for Nord you can get up to six devices
that are all protected by nord's many
different layers of security and at the
end of the day you don't have to take my
word for it you can go try it out and if
it's not useful to you you get all your
money back for 30 days so it's like a
trial period oh and nordvpn just turned
11 years old and so if you click the
link in my description it is nordvpn.com
Johnny Harris for limited time you will
get a free Mystery Gift not totally sure
what it is but who doesn't like a free
mystery gift thank you nordvpn for
sponsoring today's video let's get back
into the map I gotta get out of here
because things are about to heat up we
got a lot more to cover on these coups
the next coup has to do with Spain well
actually more like Spain's colonies
foreign
Spain's Glory Days have come and gone
they are a declining Empire and there is
Major resistance in their colonies
especially in Cuba Puerto Rico and the
Philippines meanwhile the U.S is a
rising Empire and they already are
pretty uncomfortable with Spain having
colonies like a hundred miles off their
Coast but at the same time they don't
love the idea of true Independence for
places like Cuba or Puerto Rico these
are strategic Islands right in the US's
neighborhood and like Hawaii American
companies have money invested
particularly in Cuba Independence might
mean them getting kicked out so the U.S
delves into this fight between Spain and
their colonies they use the explosion of
an American Navy ship as their excuse
even though it was likely an accident
not an attack but sometimes stories
matter more than truth so the U.S sends
in troops to liberate the rebels
fighting against their Spanish
colonizers promising them Independence
not only in Cuba and Puerto Rico but
later over here in the Philippines in
Guam these local uprisings eventually
drive out the Spanish and in all of
these cases the U.S renege on their
promise to give Independence to these
locals and they figure out ways to
govern Cuba and Puerto Rico indirectly
themselves the U.S has just piggybacked
off several Independence movements to
enact several coups at once allowing
them to install pro-american leaders and
a Navy Base in Cuba and eventually
annexing Puerto Rico and Guam which they
still control and the Philippines which
they held for 48 years again I made a
whole video about this one too if you
want to go deeper anyway we got to move
a little quicker here because we're not
going to get through all these coups
let's move on okay so we're over here in
Nicaragua it's 1909
there's a bunch of powerful American
companies here but a new president comes
to power vowing to regulate them the US
is not going to let this happen so the
secretary of state starts spreading
rumors to smear this guy this President
saying that he's building a canal that
would compete with the Panama Canal but
really they're just upset because
Nicaragua was taking loans from Europe
the U.S keeps painting this guy as a war
criminal and someone worthy of being
thrown out
so push comes to shove and the U.S sends
ships to both of Nicaragua's coasts they
assemble a bunch of Marines in Panama
basically just flexing on Nicaragua and
telling the president to step down and
the benefit of being a rising superpower
is that it worked he has no choice but
to step down and soon a leader that the
U.S likes comes to power the coup is
complete and really this is the first of
many instances of the US meddling in
Nicaragua a few years later the U.S is
back in the region for another coup in
next door Honduras this one was plotted
by a band of private American citizens
and it follows a similar pattern a new
president comes to town in this case
directly inspired by Nicaragua's
president and he wants to take back
control of the country from American
businesses in this case we're talking
about bananas the banana companies were
not going to let this happen and it was
mostly this guy a banana businessman
Named Sam the banana man he's not going
to let this pesky president run his
country no so he assembles his own
militia he literally buys a surplus Navy
ship loads it up with weapons and starts
his campaign to get this President out
he sails from New Orleans to the coast
of Honduras and he literally invades the
country with like a private Army wait
what where's the US government in all
this they also didn't like the political
direction of Honduras either so they
just sort of stood back let this private
invasion happen and then at the critical
moment the U.S steps in to order a
ceasefire basically bullying the
president to step down he had no way
forward no defense so he resigns
[Music]
and the banana man's leader of choice
takes the presidency giving the banana
businessman land and a unique status to
import anything he needs tax-free and
wait for it he refunds him for all of
the coup expenses using public Honduran
money this banana man literally
overthrew the government and made
Honduras pay for it wow
okay so let's move forward to the 50s
where the coup becomes a more useful
tool in the American toolkit there's
this new US agency dedicated to
collecting and analyzing information
from all over the world meaning for
spying they call it the Central
Intelligence Agency the CIA and it
completely revolutionizes the art of the
coup oh and at this point the US is now
a full-blown Global superpower no longer
just looking in their own neighborhood
but rather at the whole world map
investing huge resources into fighting
their Global rival and its communist
ideology
so this gets us to Iran 1953.
where Iran had just elected a new star
politician Mohammed mozadek he rises the
power believing that Iran must take back
control of its most valuable natural
resource oil which at the time was
completely controlled by a British
company called the anglo-iranian oil
company we know it today as BP mosavec
is done with this let's kick the British
out and take back our oil but like the
U.S Britain is not happy with Iranians
trying to take back their resources so
they warned that if they do this there
will be consequences
so the British catch a quick meeting
with the cia's Middle East guy who was
passing through London and they pitch
him on this idea let's throw out Musa
deck the CIA is like okay and they kind
of sniff communist Vibes on most of that
with this big desire to nationalize
Iran's oil or at least they tell
themselves they do so the CIA agrees and
they secretly send this guy to Iran he's
the Middle East bureau chief Kermit
Roosevelt he's like in his 30s oh and
yes he is the grandson of another big
coup guy Teddy Roosevelt who I have gone
into in other videos Roosevelt sneaks
into Iran and is given a million
taxpayer dollars to use quote in any way
that would bring about the fall of
mozadek so now there's American CIA
agents in Iran secretly trying to
overthrow the government and it's a
rocky start at first with a bunch of
failures but they start using their
money to get traction bribing
politicians religious clerics and other
leaders to say divisive and
controversial things about mozadek they
hire locals to Stage attacks against
religious leaders making it look like
they had been ordered to do so by
mozadek but really they were just
getting paid by the CIA to do this and
with enough time and money they create
an atmosphere of chaos and hostility and
distrust among the public oh and there's
weapons the CIA stashes enough weapons
and explosives to support a quote 10 000
man gorilla Organization for six months
like just in case they need to like
start a full-on conflict the result of
all of this is more violence and Chaos
that engulfs the capital shops are being
destroyed bullets are flying into
mosques people are beaten and thousands
of paid demonstrators flood the street
the city falls into Anarchy all of it
orchestrated by CIA money and in the end
this all results in a bloody shootout at
mozadek's house he eventually gives up
and turns himself in he's put through a
sham trial and found guilty of treason
and sentenced to three years in solitary
confinement and then house arrest where
he stayed until his death the previous
ruler of Iran Muhammad Reza Shah which
just means king had fled the country but
now with the democratically elected
mosadec gone and with the backing of the
U.S and UK he could charter a flight
back into Iran and take control
crowns himself in a tradition which goes
back 25 centuries his title is king of
kings and he becomes emperor
the U.S really came out on top here they
got what they wanted they now have an
American friendly dictator in a powerful
country in the Middle East who is now
welcoming American oil companies to get
in on one of the largest oil reserves on
Earth under the Shah Iran becomes a
brutal police state he executed Military
Officers student leaders anyone
associated with mosadec he set up a
secret police force and life was brutal
so brutal that in 1979 the frustration
of Iranians burst forth in Mass protests
that ran the Shah out of office and
replaced him with an inspiring new
leader who would turn Iran into an
Islamic Republic built in part off of
foundation of resentment for the U.S
having meddled in their country the
Islamic Republic has held power ever
since and has morphed into the
oppressive theocracy we know today
though maybe not for long
before we go on a quick reminder that
all of these coups these plans to
overthrow leaders in other countries did
not require American votes or consensus
or approval of Congress it was usually
just a few key men in government
buildings in Washington DC making this
happen these people would go on to
define the Cold War and shape so many
covert operations around the world that
many of which will never know about
okay let's keep going the next year in
Guatemala the CIA tried to pull the same
Playbook that they used in Iran once
again targeting a leader that the people
had elected but who wanted to take back
the country's resources for the people
to break up these American monopolies
that controlled the country's
electricity and railroad the president
even starts to seize land from one
massive banana company it was often
unused land that he wanted to
redistribute to the locals who could
Farm it and feed their families and
hopefully climb out of the system of
endemic poverty in the country once
again I made a whole video on this the
geopolitics of bananas in Central
America but the fact is that the US
decided that they had to defend the
banana companies or else more communist
reforms would spread so the U.S
president and Secretary of State ordered
an overthrow and the CIA got right to
work the CIA hand selects a leader that
they want to be in power and then they
start giving equipment and training to a
bunch of Guatemalan Exiles and private
soldiers they set up a secret operation
based on the outskirts of Miami they
start delivering weapons to the Panama
Canal but like the other coups it can't
just all be about weapons they gotta own
the information space so they create a
radio station that sounds like it's a
local Guatemalan radio station but
really it's being operated out of a
small town in Florida and they start
publishing fake news about an uprising
unrest a rebellion and then at the same
time the fighters that the CIA had
trained and armed invades Guatemala
Pilots start dropping bombs on fuel
tanks and Military posts and airports
but they weren't starting a full-on war
they weren't trying to cause real damage
they wanted it to feel like a domestic
uprising like a war was on the horizon
to freak people out and for many it
totally worked they thought that this
was a real Uprising and had no idea that
the CIA was behind it all but the
president knew what was up he had messed
with the USA and now he's hearing about
it military leaders in his Circle are
feeling the pressure from the big bully
from the north and they turn on him and
he eventually surrenders on his way out
the president addresses his people makes
it very clear that quote the United
Fruit Company in collaboration with the
United States is responsible for what is
happening to us and just like that one
president is out and the hand-picked CIA
option is in this new regime is brutal
and goes on to do horrible things
detaining people they thought were
Communists killing prisoners breaking up
labor unions and in the process
restoring the banana company's land and
ensuring that they maintained their hold
on this economy this kicks off an era in
Guatemala of more political
assassinations and instability something
that still plagues the country today and
yet to this day there is no evidence
that the Soviets were ever slightly
interested in Guatemala communism was
once again the excuse but really this
was about securing American business
interests tearing a country apart for
bananas bananas
are the best for you
all right let's go to Africa so it's
1960 here in the center of Africa a
country called Congo
they just gained independence from
Belgium and they have an election and
this guy Patrice lumumba wins becomes
the Prime Minister but immediately over
in Washington the Communist alarm Bells
instantly start sounding off because
we're in the middle of the Cold War and
Congo is a Place full of tons of Natural
Resources including loads of uranium the
main ingredient for nuclear bombs this
is at a time when Americans are keeping
gas masks next to their bed and have
hordes of canned goods in their
basements and officials in Washington
can't risk Congo falling into the
influence of the Soviet Union so they
start focusing on this prime minister
the CIA director called him quote an
urgent and Prime objective that should
quote be a high priority of our covert
action so they pull a more political
coup than the ones before they start
allying with lumumba's political enemies
and Congo's former colonizer Belgium
they bribe politicians they fund
protests and labor movements and they
circulate propaganda similar ingredients
to the previous coups and when the
moment is right all these bribed
politicians do what the CIA them too
they've removed lumumba from power and
the CIA is right there giving money and
intelligence and advice to the new
government this political solution was
actually not the first try the CIA had
tried to assassinate lumumba in the past
but all of those attempts failed which
is why they turned to hijacking and
manipulating Congolese politics a brand
new democracy supporting the people who
would eventually go on to put lumumba in
front of a Congolese and Belgian firing
squad making this effectively a
political assassination supported from
an ocean away and yet there's so much
gray area in these coups in this case
it's really tough to prove that the
cia's support was the key factor in
lumumba's assassination it's debated to
this day an effective foreign sponsored
coup works like this operating in the
shadows fueling divisions appealing to
the worst Demons of the people on the
ground through money through influence
all right let's move on to the Caribbean
in the 1960s
there's a brutal dictator here in the
Dominican Republic I mean this guy's
really bad he's rumored to feed his
opponents to sharks but anyway what the
U.S cares about is that there's fear
that the Communist Revolution could
happen at any moment so the CIA sends
weapons to a group of Hitmen who go
assassinate this guy it ends up being an
ambush and a car chase they're
successful in taking him out ending his
31-year rule
[Music]
eventually the U.S sends in forces to
occupy the Dr to make sure that a
leftist candidate doesn't come to power
they restore order and eventually a U.S
friendly candidate is elected
[Music]
okay so now we have to head over to
Vietnam in 1963.
and boy this is a way bigger one than we
have time for but we're trying to focus
on the coup element of this Vietnam was
divided in two between communist and
pro-western governments the U.S needs
the South to stay on their side but
Washington starts to lose confidence in
this guy the South's leader he's losing
a grip on the country and the U.S fears
that communism will take over the whole
country of Vietnam the CIA rolls up its
sleeves it's time for another coup this
time they focus on a South Vietnamese
General who also doesn't love the
president and he agrees to do the cia's
bidding and when given the signal the
general directs his military to seize
the airport and radio stations and they
block off highways they March to the
presidential Palace a bloody shootout
goes down and this president president
DM escapes happens to be with his
brother but it's not going well for them
so he realizes that he needs to set up a
meeting to surrender they're going to
meet at a Catholic Church this was
probably going to be a peaceful meeting
but when the generals arrive they just
kill him on the spot
saying quote to kill the weed you must
Pull up The Roots meaning in order to
solve the problem DM Must Die Exile was
not enough now the U.S actually didn't
plan for this to happen they didn't want
to kill this guy it was not an official
order from Washington but they made this
coup happen JFK is said to be really
distraught about this the first American
Catholic President behind the coup that
killed the first Vietnamese Catholic
President and incidentally JFK was
assassinated 20 days later and one
National Security journalist argues that
DM's assassination actually had a
greater impact on American history than
the murder of JFK because it locked the
U.S into a decade of conflict in Vietnam
which ballooned into a long War ending
in an embarrassing defeat and a
political crisis at home one of the few
coups where the U.S actually had to deal
with the aftermath
[Music]
okay let's blast through a few of these
really quickly I'm going to skirt over
some details here it's 1964 and Brazil
is potentially veering off into
communism with the rise of a new leftist
leader lucky for the CIA there's already
a coup being plotted against him so the
US military just shows up with ships off
the coast of Brazil they airlift in a
bunch of ammunition and supplies they
didn't end up having to do much actually
instead they just stood by with
reinforcements and watched the Brazilian
coup go down the leftist leader goes
down and a new leader comes in
in 1973 there's a coup in Chile that is
a very complicated story with
conflicting accounts and we went down a
super deep rabbit hole and we've decided
that because the evidence is not rock
solid we're going to cut it for time but
definitely some crazy [__] went down I'm
not saying it didn't
[Music]
okay we're back in Africa and it's the
80s and over here in Libya the dictator
murmur Gaddafi was making lots of
trouble in the region funding terrorist
groups and working to expand his
influence all over the region then he
gets a call from his neighbor Chad
asking for help against a rebellion
Gaddafi eagerly sends 4 000 troops to
occupy a huge part of the country and
makes friends with the new president by
helping him Exile his rival and soon
Qaddafi is getting greedy and
threatening to merge Chad into Libya the
U.S is not into this so Ronald Reagan
fires up the well-oiled coup machine
launching a covert War sending weapons
and cash to rebels in chat and
supporting that political opponent who
was ousted helping him fight back and it
works the president of Chad has to flee
and the U.S backed and supported leader
comes to power and now there's a
conflict and the CIA continues armying
the war even after this guy is in office
the new U.S backed leader rules brutally
for eight years until he's eventually
overthrown by a military officer and in
2013 he was charged with crimes against
humanity torture and crimes
[Music]
okay now let's go to this little island
in 1983.
it's communism again and the U.S sends
2000 troops to invade this small remote
island and remove their communist leader
they didn't really know much about this
small island and they literally had to
use tourism maps to plan their Invasion
anyway American forces move in overwhelm
the Grenadian fighters who happen to be
joined by their Cuban allies the
government collapses and the U.S
friendly leader comes to power
foreign
back down to Central America it's 1989
and we're here in Panama where the U.S
has control of a very important canal
and luckily the Panamanian dictator has
been very friendly to American interests
but the U.S starts losing confidence in
this guy wondering if he's really the
best choice ensuring the U.S maintain
easy access to their vital Canal oh and
it didn't help that this guy was
indicted in Florida on drug trafficking
and money laundering charges we gotta
get him out but the straw that broke the
camel's back for this guy was when
Panamanian troops killed an unarmed
American soldier in Panama City the U.S
is done with this guy so they invade
Panama with 27 000 troops Panama's
military is crushed and the dictator is
eventually arrested and sentenced to 40
years in prison and the U.S ensures
access to its Canal after all
foreign
[Music]
okay so now it's the end of the 1980s
and the Soviets are invading Afghanistan
and are meeting resistance from a bunch
of fighters from all over the world who
have come to Afghanistan to fight back
against the Soviet occupation many of
them with fundamentalist religious
motivations but the US doesn't care
about their motivation they just care
that they're willing to fight against
the Soviets and the Soviets puppet the
Afghan president and it totally works
with the help of the U.S these Fighters
pushed the Soviets back and successfully
run the Afghan president out of office
and as he's being run out of office he
forebodingly warns the Americans that if
they leave Afghanistan in the hands of
these Fighters that it would quote be
turned into a center for terrorism and
his prophecy was completely fulfilled
those U.S funded Fighters were people
whose names we know today Osama Bin
Laden Abu musab al-zarkawi the guy who
started the group that would eventually
become Isis those same weapons that the
U.S sent to counter the Soviets and to
affect regime change in Afghanistan
would go on to be used against American
soldiers years later when the U.S was
back orchestrating yet another regime
change after 9 11. against the very
groups they once enabled the U.S would
eventually leave Afghanistan only to
find the country immediately falling
back into Taliban rule we're almost to
the end of our list and we're now in
modern day it's 2003 and 150 000
American troops invade Iraq
they say that they are there to find and
destroy weapons of mass destruction but
their main focus is taking out this guy
Saddam Hussein which they do in a matter
of weeks Saddam fleeing into hiding and
President Bush declaring mission
accomplished establishing an
american-friendly government in Iraq
creating once again a negative byproduct
by alienating huge swaths of the Iraqi
people and army who form a bunch of
anti-American Rebel groups that go on to
fight against the American occupation
some morphing into groups like Isis who
wreak all kinds of havoc on the region
to this day once again I made a whole
video about this topic go check it out
Iraq remains a place of deep political
instability trust in government is
extremely low and the question of how
and why we did this expensive horrific
destructive coup is still something that
there aren't really good answers to
again you can go watch my video for more
on that
and this gets us to the final coup on
our list it's 2011 during a wave of
protests spreading throughout this
region trying to take down all these
strong men dictators one of which was
this guy Muammar Gaddafi the same
Gaddafi we were talking about earlier
who's like taking over Chad he's still
here and he's still a very horrible dude
and there's worry that he's gonna
potentially Massacre all of these
pro-democracy protesters so the US feels
like it must get involved to save these
protesters they rally their NATO allies
to help them but at some point the
mission switches to Total regime change
we don't know exactly how this happened
only the people in the room do but is it
surprising we've seen this long Arc of
the US using the coup as a force for
getting their way in an international
conflict it's a tried and true tool in
the American foreign policy toolkit so
it's not surprising that a coup becomes
a solution during these difficult
decision-making processes so anyway the
target becomes Gaddafi and now NATO
drones are firing missiles at his Convoy
and he eventually gets captured and gets
killed on the spot Libya has been in
chaos ever since but it's not like it
was a great place under Gaddafi and once
again we're in a gray area where we
don't know the history that didn't
happen or how things could have turned
out different if the US didn't get
involved that debate lives on
okay so that's our list these are our
coups that we decided to go over in this
video there are so many more that we
could have mentioned my purpose in doing
this broad back-to-back history of
american-led coups was so that we can
see patterns that emerge how a rising
superpower became really good at
removing leaders that didn't align with
their way of seeing the world or in a
lot of cases who were not friendly to
American business interests but let's be
clear the US didn't invent this this is
something that powerful countries and
empires have always done what
characterizes u.s-led coups especially
during the Cold War was how the
overthrow of these governments often
Stamped Out new democracies budding
Democratic movements replacing them with
authoritarian leaders who would go on to
oppress the people with the support and
backing of the United States and in the
process redirecting the country's
history lately Russia has been meddling
in the election process of the United
States and I've been reflecting on my
feelings towards that the violation
nation of having an external power
sowing doubt and polarization and fear
in my own democracy in my own Society it
feels like such a violation and it is
this is giving me just a tiny taste of
what it feels like to have an outside
power pulling the strings in your
country tearing it apart for their own
purposes and in the process creating
more problems for the people and for the
United States itself undermining any
semblance of democracy or development
all in the name of keeping the U.S on
top and dominant over the globe
[Music]
foreign